back to other news a lawyer with ties to
former Trump campaign chairman Paul
Manafort is headed for prison chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge is live tonight with a landmark
decision and the Russia's Special
Counsel investigation good evening
Catherine thank you read this morning 33
year-old Alex Van der Swann entered
federal court here in Washington DC
where he was sentenced for lying to
federal investigators that carries a
maximum penalty of five years in prison
but instead the london-based attorney
whose father in lies a Russian oligarch
with ties to President Putin got 30 days
in prison a twenty thousand dollar fine
in two months of supervised release the
Dutch lawyer worked with Rick gates the
former business partner of Paul Manafort
Gates is now cooperating with Special
Counsel investigators mr. vanderzwaan
also worked with manna fort who was
briefly the Trump campaign chairman and
now faces money laundering and tax fraud
charges based on court filing Special
Counsel investigators are exploring
contacts between the three men and a
suspected operative for Russian
intelligence a newly public memo for the
first time explains the broad authority
that allow the special counsel to
investigate events prior to the 2016
campaign the four-page memo was drafted
by Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein in August 2017 with entire
sections blacked out what's visible
shows Rosenstein gave Muller the power
to go beyond allegations of Russian
collusion to mana for its work in the
Ukraine and allegations that he quote
committed a crime or crimes arising out
of payments he received from the
Ukrainian government before and during
the tenure of President Viktor
Yanukovych in a separate development
today the wife of fired FBI director
Andrew McCabe went on the record calling
last year a nightmare for her family
writing in The Washington Post dr. Jill
McCabe who ran unsuccessfully for a
Virginia State Senate seat in 2015 said
her husband did not campaign for her
despite this widely circulated photo she
said was meant for family and friends
dr. McCabe also said the FBI ethics
panel concluded there was no conflict
for her husband when she received more
than $600,000 from Democrats including a
longtime Clinton ally because her
husband's involvement in the Clinton
email case came after the contributions
were made and the race was over quote
I've spent countless hours trying to
understand how the president and so many
others can share such destructive lives
about me I want people to know that the
whole story that everything is based on
is just false and utterly absurd but
bureau critics say the ethics findings
were wrong and indicate a culture
problem
monsignor FBI executive spread all right
Catherine thank you all